bueno
[Música]
no no
y
yo
quería ser indiana jones
[Música]
pero no quería ser la novia de indiana
jones yo quería ser él
porque soy curiosa porque me gusta el
misterio porque me gusta la aventura y
también
me encanta investigar todas esas cosas
de la historia humana que todavía están
por verse
bueno aquí me surgieron dos noticias una
mala noticia y una buena pero voy a
empezar por las malas
las malas noticias
no podía ser indiana jones
primero porque es el personaje de el
cine un personaje que ha hecho varias
películas segundo porque es muy difícil
que yo pudiera encontrar el arca
perdida' y tercero porque me faltaba ese
maravilloso sombrero y ese maravilloso
látigo
pero aquí viene la buena noticia
cuando mis ojos nos llegaban a la altura
de la mesa de la cocina mi mamá puso en
mis manos libros
y saben qué pasó
fui la arqueóloga que encontró todas
esas expediciones y fui el príncipe y
fiel mendigo
y fiel extranjero y fui el asesino
serial
y fui doña flor y sus dos maridos
y fui al primer encuentro y también fui
el último adiós
walking
porque pasa algo mágico cuando uno abre
un libro no importa en qué formato
sabe qué es eso mágico que ocurre un
pacto
un pacto donde el lector cree aunque
sepa racionalmente que no es así
cree en esa comunidad que el autor crea
con lugares con personajes con
recreaciones con argumentos y al creerle
se identifica
o me van a decir que todos los niños del
mundo y muchos adultos no les hubiese
gustado estudiar en howard estoy segura
que sí
miren cuando yo era chica leí una saga
de susan perrault que se llamaba
verónica ánimo verónica y verónica al
timón
miren verónica al timón fue para mí
como una aventura tan extraordinaria que
yo dije algún día voy a estudiar timonel
de vela
bueno pasados muchos años pude hacerlo
pero en el momento en que yo estaba
aferrada a ese timón con el viento en la
cara no era solamente cumplir un sueño
cumplir una materia pendiente
yo era verónica
yo me había identificado con ella
y todo esto que ocurre con las palabras
ocurre saben por qué porque las palabras
no son solo sonidos son significados
y hay un significado para cada uno de
nosotros diferente al otro
en mi familia
me enteré cuando era chica que la gran
george sand
y digo la grande george sand
representarán como muchos la conocerán
muchos no sabrán de ella era una gran
escritora del siglo 19
cuyo nombre verdadero era amandine juppé
era tal la pasión que ella tenía por el
significado de las palabras
que se cambió el nombre se puso el
nombre de hombre y se vestía de hombre
para poder escribir y para poder editar
en un look en un momento en un lugar
donde para hacerlo una mujer hubiese
sido un escándalo
miren como esto las cosas a veces del
universo
me enteré hace poco que una de sus
mayores obras saben cómo se llama
indiana
además fue el amante de chopin son mis
raíces
eso es otro cantar
[Música]
pero cuando uno está introducido en esta
magia que producen los textos
hay algo que sucede que son un abanico
de posibilidades en mi caso hubo dos que
me atraparon fuertemente toda la vida
una fue el desafío con eso de sanador
que también tiene la palabra aún la
palabra que escrita nos hace decir cosas
que la oralidad no nos permite
eso sanador nos hace en un momento
recurrir a escribir nuestras propias
historias y formar nuestras propias
comunidades con nuestra imaginación
inventando nuestros propios lugares
poniéndonos a nosotros como personajes o
no
y saben que eso logra que terminemos
recuerdos y emociones
por otro lado
transmitir pasión
pobre del que no puede transmitir pasión
hay una anécdota muy cortita que dice
que la profesora de literatura al gran
poeta en la luz
federico garcía lorca le dijo dedícate
otra cosa
servir para esto para escribir gracias a
dios estaba por ahí dando vueltas su
profesor de música
saben que hizo le transmitió pasión con
pocas cosas humildemente le dijo primero
tus versos tienen musicalidad segundo es
lo que te gusta hacer
entonces para transmitir pasión hace más
de 20 años yo formé un taller literario
palabras a bordo
porque me gustan los barcos palabra
sabor
en ese taller literario si alguno se
pregunta qué pasa en un taller literario
puede suceder cualquier cosa es un
espacio maravilloso yo digo que los
talleres literarios son como células
clandestinas confabulando a espaldas del
mundo contra la cotidianeidad
y cuando uno mezcla
el poder político de la palabra o sea el
grito la reflexión mezcla el buen humor
mezcla la confianza mezclar la
imaginación porque saben que en un
taller literario la protagonista de soy
yo ni siquiera los alumnos
mire lo que les digo ni siquiera los
textos la gran protagonista es la
imaginación y cuando uno la mezcla con
todo eso que traemos en nuestro interior
que es lo que surge
el arte
el arte que nos distingue de los demás
seres humanos
que logra que seres como nosotros
podamos imaginar y crear con belleza
entonces si nosotros tomamos el desafío
de meternos en esta magia de los libros
seguramente por más vicisitudes que
tengamos en la vida seguramente va a ser
una gran aventura
una vez me dieron algo y yo hoy se los
quiero regalar porque para mí fue un
regalo
recuerden siempre sólo se vive una vez
salvo por la literatura
[Música]